[Musique]
nous allons tout tenter
l'histoire les aventures des aventures
nous allons vous conter l'histoire des
aventures de renard
renard 20 seulement des maires de
l'hérault
il ya peu
impressionnant
il va jusqu'à se passer
[Musique]
devant l'échec de brens l'ours et de
tibère le chat noble le lion décide
d'envoyer grimbert le blaireau à
maupertuis grains verts le blaireau
étant le cousin de renard il avait toute
chance de réussir à le ramener à la cour
à cers grain vais rentrer vite
quel grand plaisir et entrevoir écouter
- renard vous malisse ont poussé tout le
monde à bout je suis chargé par le roi
de vous porter la troisième semaine
[Musique]
vous devez vous présenter à la cour
hélas le conserver aucun espoir
vous serez condamné à la peine capitale
lisez cette lettre portant laisser les
royaux vous jugerez de la gravité de la
situation
mais sur noble le lion souverain maître
de toutes les régions et de tous les
animaux du monde mandat renard on est
derniers supplice s'il ne vient demain
répondre à la clameur élevé contre lui
dans ma cour
il devra se munir de la corde pour le
pendre
à grimbert conseillez moi
que dois-je faire pour ne pas être
pendus hélas personne ne viendra m'aider
à vous défendre
mettez donc à profil peu de temps qu'il
vous reste qu'on fait c'est vous à
défaut de prêtres je vous écouterez je
me repens d'avoir fait trop de mal à l
angle
je ne puis me rappeler tous les autres
tours que j'ai joué les personnes à la
cour du roi ne peut se plaindre de moi
je ne parle pas bien sûr des poules des
paysans de brun et du miel de tibère et
des souris de tout cela je bats ma
coulpe et je veux faire pénitence renard
vous vous êtes bien confessé prométhée à
présent de ne plus recommencer
je le promets
[Musique]
oh
gardez ce château en bonne état vous
avez ici des provisions pour de longues
années
je vous recommande a lieu est prié le
pour qu'ils me laissent revenir bientôt
ainsi s'achève notre histoire provisoire
je suis pour
sans grimpeur des renards
bonjour